face down and barefoot salvadorian
refugee
victoria esperanza salazar died on a
roadside in the mexican resort town of
tulum
police officers threw her body in the
back of a pickup
after restraining her on the pavement a
state prosecutor says
offices used excessive force
the police technique of body control
that was applied and the level of force
used was disproportionate
in moderate and with a high risk to life
salazar's mother says police treated her
daughter like an animal
they already gave a report that my
daughter's neck was broken and they
broke a lot of ribs
because there were three men and a woman
on top of her
the death is an embarrassment for mexico
just as it began hosting a u.n
summit on gender equality on monday
mexico has one of the worst rates of
gender-based violence in the world
last year an average of 10 women died
there every day
and the day before the summit families
of femicide victims rallied outside the
president's residence
president lopez obrador says those
responsible for salazar's death will be
punished
i want to say to her family members to
salvadoran and mexican women
to the women of the world to all men and
women that those responsible will be
punished they're already in the process
of being prosecuted and there will be no
impunity
it's not clear why salazar was arrested
but her family members say they'll fight
to give her the dignity
she was denied in death barbara angopa
al jazeera let's bring in raul benitez
manat who's
a professor at the national university
of mexico he joins us now live via skype
from mexico city
uh mexico's president says she was
murdered what are your thoughts on this
woman's death
yes the mexican president lopez obrador
accepts
the responsibility of the police in
tulum
with the the assassination of victoria
salazar
in the streets of this resort city
this is very grave because it shows the
the way that mexico treats the central
americans
in the country and the the mexican
government has many problems right now
with the salvadorian government
for this case do you think that her
nationality had anything to do with it
yes the nationality of victoria salazar
affects the relationship between the
migrants and the policies
is a case who shows the gravity of the
way that the mexican authorities treat
the the central americans in their way
to the united states or if they
decide to work in mexico as in is the
case of victoria salazar
are there other cases where the police
have been accused of heavy-handedness
than in their attitude towards migrants
in mexico
yes many migrants crosses the border
without documents and majority of them
of them came from honduras el salvador
and guatemala
and other countries african countries
etc but
a few a few of them are from other parts
of the world and
with this the mexican police the mexican
military stops the migrants
but they find a
highest highways to to cross to the
united states
in some cases they go to tourist places
to work
this is the case of victoria salazar in
tulum
where there are many tourists from the
from europe from the u.s
but she was working there in the
services
sector in the church sector and
in the street the the police capture hg
and causes the the problem the
assassination
of this woman and what do you make of
mexico's
president's uh response to this uh this
incident
um just how how big a diplomatic spat
has this caused between mexico and
salvador
yes the the southern government uh
critics the mexican government for this
but
the mexican president accepts the
responsibility but this is one thing
another thing is
to do things to stop this
this treatment to the the migrants this
is different because
on the one hand the the the high level
authorities
said that they respect the human rights
but on the other hand the police in the
streets
treat very hard the the migrants the
abuse of
the use of force is incredible it's like
like the
your floyd assassination in minneapolis
in may of 2020 it's exactly the same
case
really good to talk to you professor
many thanks indeed for being with us
okay okay